In one of their more desperate attempts to
kill off SCP-682, the Hard to Destroy Reptile,
the SCP Foundation employed the use of SCP-3802,
a bottle of anti-baldness ointment
known as “hare growth by dado.”
But not just any hair: If you
apply this to the skin of an adult,
they’ll break out in huge, painful,
tumorous masses that turn into giant,
Flemish rabbits. This anomalous chemical
was spritzed onto SCP-682 by the sprinklers,
causing the beast horrific pain and
massive, unchecked tumor growth.
As these tumors broke away and became
giant rabbits, they tore off 40%
of SCP-682’s body mass. However, it didn’t stick,
as SCP-682 ate the rabbits while it was
regenerating. Back to the drawing board!